when we have a look at Newton's famous
laws of motion what we're going to do is
we're going to get them in verbal form
right but then we're gonna translate it
to our language we're gonna get
equations and all those kinds of things
variables and how they relate to each
other so in order to write those down
and know what any of that is talking
about we need to introduce a whole bunch
of terms and relate them to each other
okay so what we'll do is we'll start all
the way back at the language of learning
to in emotion okay displacement velocity
acceleration displacement velocity
acceleration
okay so we just start with this guy
right now we call this we tend to name
it X okay now when you define a velocity
the easiest way to define it is in terms
of displacement you already told me it's
the X on the T right
so V is DX DT so far so good
okay displacement what units are those
we already mentioned this the symbian
meters right which applies that for
velocity you're going to get well meters
per second is the most common by far
them just like before we define
acceleration recursively right in terms
of velocity a is the change in velocity
over time right so since what you're
doing is you're adding another time you
know on the denominator that's why we
have the familiar meters per second
squared okay now remember I said before
you division mechanics is three emission
plus Maps
okay so now let's think about mass fer
what happens to all these things that
we've had on mass okay so we call mass M
format and even though there's a lot of
different units per length and once
didn't tire we settle on one that's the
most common sense for mass its kilograms
okay
now if you think about something having
velocity and then you add mass to the
mixture okay that's a whole new unit
right velocity as well as mass right so
in other words right if you're running
out how fast do you run like maybe 10 12
hours an hour or something like that I'm
not very fast
okay you ready at 10 kilometers an hour
and I don't weigh very much but if
you've got like a truck that told me at
10 kilometers an hour right its mass is
so much more so what's what this
quantity is is larger even though we're
both moving at the same velocity okay so
we call this unit we call it momentum
okay now we had X for this placement V
velocity if acceleration M for mass
clearly we cannot use M so what most men
division centered on is PE don't ask me
because I'm just telling you okay so the
idea is that if two objects have the
same velocity but they have different
mass then they all have different
momentum in fact momentum is defined as
mass times velocity okay so the momentum
would be greater if you had the same
bossy but you increase the mass of
something okay what you want to think
about it this way like I said I'm a
pretty small guy right so if I was
trying to tackle someone I was riding at
someone okay I would have to run much
faster then a guy who's like you know
began stocking could just like walk up
to someone and say you know stop okay
whereas I i'd have to like make a run up
from like 100 meters over there i had to
get a lot more velocity I think this
bigger to compensate for my smaller mass
okay sort of product that's how these
fit together now because it's a product
of these units the units are kilogram
meters per second that's a bit weird
but that's the quantity it's a product
right now in exactly the same way that
you can consider what happens when you
add multiply velocity by mass you get
the same thing for acceleration right
and we call this a force
okay thank goodness they picked a word
with a unique letter on the front okay
so that tends to be a capital F right
now just like this is mass times
velocity or would you'd expect this to
be mass times acceleration okay
now just like we took these units right
this would be there's gonna be kilograms
there there's gonna be meters and then
there's going to be two lots of seconds
right that's what it is but that's super
awkward it's really weird
so instead of saying this it gets a
whole new name named after the guy who
really pioneered this these things are
called movements okay so one you two
keeping with all of the units that we've
used to you one Newton is the force
required right to move a single kilogram
and accelerate it at one meter per
second squared that's what a Newton is
wonderful
okay did no any questions about that so
far
you see how it all fits together I found
that the first time I learned this I
found the table really helpful because
it shows you the relationship between
each before I leave off this I'm some
interesting things when you look at this
row in here right this is this is the
motion room you see this right this is
how something is moving okay you can see
motion it's a visible thing right if
something is moving in front of you you
can see it happening but this road right
this is not about motion this is about
forcing acceleration you can't see this
you can't see at something that's
accelerating or a force right all the
forces we know if I say gravity I or the
electromagnetic force they can be
exerting for us or you know making
certain happen and you can't see what's
making these things happen
right they miserable but they're not
visible okay I'm the most famous example
of this was that a guy was uh he was a
botanist and he was looking at in the
telescope's telescope microscope is
looking into a microscope and all these
bits of pollen in here right and they're
all suspended on his well what's that
last thing cool yeah Eddie noticed right
they can think of a slide but anyway
doesn't matter she's got all these
little bits of pollen right and what do
you notice was that they were moving
they're moving they thought that's kind
of weird
why are they moving all I've got is is
these bits of pollen that's all I've put
on there okay how what's causing them to
move okay and they'll kind of jiggling
about in this kind of took him random
motion right so the motion was visible
but he could not see what was pushing
them around okay it was Einstein who
looked at this in his head
there's not like some people thought
this just mysteriously you know floating
around this is what they do
he said no there's got to be something
in here it's got to be things that are
too small for the microscope to see that
are kind of nudging them around right
and hence the theory of these small
things because atoms right once and
months and lots of them billions of them
that are all colliding and pushing
things around and the guy who saw it is
the botanist of these things brown or
brown inside man so the motion of these
little objects that have been pushed
around by invisible forces invisible us
it's called Brownian motion go look this
up so at the point is that motion you
can see but forces you cannot I'll give
you another example have a look at me
right now now just forget about my arms
vertically horizontally said axis okay
I'm not moving right I'm in the same
spot but there are forces acting on me
you just can't see them right I can
think of two right there's something
that's sticking me to the ground namely
gravity okay so gravity's pulling down
on my feet you can't see it but it's
doing it right how come I don't fall
through the floor we'll get to it but
but in the short of it there's another
force that's acting upwards which is why
I'm not moving anywhere
okay so forces you cannot see them
that's the important thing I want you to
get